[Music]
I'm very hopeful that you know I finally
get a chance to to meet the girl that I
want to spend the rest of my life with
on Mondays premiere of The Bachelor Nick
vile met the ladies vying for a chance
to become his wife
including the good Jonathan Vanessa oh
wow it's just sweet it I can't don't get
it the Electra yes it's a keeper
the weird you're a wiener in my book
we're super not delicious
the cringe-worthy my girlfriends were
like no he's a complete he's okay but I
don't believe them or anyone else two
things and a just plain outrageous hi
I hear you like a good hug but it was
Rachel a 31 year old attorney from
Dallas who made the best first
impression
Monday's premiere wasn't only about new
romances Nick also got a taste of his
past this is gonna be a great season new
imagine getting to date Nick yeah 36
year old reconnected with his exes Andi
Dorfman and Kaitlyn Bristowe on Jimmy
Kimmel's here for the right reasons post
bachelor special can I just say thank
you for not picking me yeah you ever
contact or talk to each other or
anything like that we're friends we are
like that we're friendly
I mean this is so awkward
[Music]
you